mais voilà encore des années de
procédure et cette question toujours
ouvertes par cette enquête inédite les
fabricants d'armes peuvent ils être tenu
pour responsable d'éventuels crimes ou
bavures commis avec le matériel qu'ils
ont vendu la france on a entendu est le
troisième exportateur d'armes au monde
qu'est ce que ce secteur représente pour
notre économie et puis dans ce monde de
plus en plus incertain notre pays
va-t-il conserver ce levier d'influencé
de puissance au prix de quels éventuel
compromis avec les principes d'un état
de droit
ce sont quelques unes des nombreuses
questions avec lesquels nous laisse ce
film made in france au service de la
guerre d' alice odiot et sophie nivelles
cardinal et pour approfondir à présent
j'accueille sur ce plateau jean
dominique merchet bonjour vous êtes
journaliste à l'opinion spécialiste des
questions de défense à vos côtés aymeric
élus un bonjour bonjour chargé de
plaidoyer sur la question des armes chez
amnesty international france
nous sommes également avec guillaume
gontard bonjour vous êtes jour sénateur
écologiste de l'isère vice président de
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense et des forces armées ici au
sénat et puis hervé grandjean bonjour
vous êtes le porte parole du ministère
des armées alors ce film on l'a vu un
s'inscrit dans un contexte celui du
conflit israélo-palestinien mais ils
posent des questions plus larges
un mot d'abord peut-être sur ce regard
qui est engagée dans ce film aymeric est
loin est ce que c'est une bonne manière
de poser ce débat sur la responsabilité
des fabricants d'armes
alors il ya différentes façons de de
rentrer chez eux le dossier
dans tous les cas ce qui s'est passé
concernant l affaire chou et bar est
assez unique
c'est la première fois que l'on voit des
composants français retrouver sur une
scène de possibles crimes de guerre et
en cela cela ouvre du coup un nouveau
champ un nouveau chapitre de réflexion
sur la responsabilité des industriels
c'est un point de départ c'est inédit ce
n'était jamais arrivé c'est la première
fois qu'il ya une instruction en france
et donc la plainte a été acceptée a été
reconnu comme recevable l'instruction
est en cours au tj maintenant à la
justice enquête
voilà exactement mais sur le principe
jean dominique merchet cette démarche
des avocats des victimes pour établir la
responsabilité d'un d'un fabricant
français sur un théâtre de guerre qui
est en dehors du territoire français
vous vous trouvez cette démarche
pertinente
en tout cas ça témoigne d'une nouvelle
sensibilité sur cette question des
exportations d'armements pendant très
longtemps en france ça faisait juste un
certain consensus il y avait évidemment
quelques organisations dont amnesty qui
dénonçait toujours ça mais globalement
il y avait peu de contestations peu de
cette question se posait pas vraiment la
question depuis quelques années et
notamment ce qui a été le je pense le
facteur déclenchant ça a été la guerre
que mènent les saoudiens et les emiratis
au yémen et ça ça a été un moment où
l'opinion a commencé assez modestement
en france par rapport à ce qu'on peut
voir dans d'autres pays dans d'autres
pays européens notamment refait c'est
souvent en allemagne par exemple en
italie au 6 mai
mais en allemagne très fortement et donc
en france quand même on sent que quelque
chose a bougé autour de cette question
des ventes d'armes
récemment et sur la question des
fabricants d'armes
alors il faut rappeler d'entrée je crois
aux téléspectateurs qu'en france un
fabricant d'armes un industriel qui
fabrique les arts n'a pas le droit de
les exporter
sauf à obtenir une autorisation
spécifique délivrée par le gouvernement
donc c'est un commerce extrêmement
régulé ce n'est pas un commerce libre
c'est même le contraire d'un commerce
lips est un commerce interdit qui fait
l'objet d'autorisation de la part du
gouvernement
donc c'est à chaque fois une décision
politique donc on ne peut pas faire
porter la responsabilité à l'industriel
industriels il obéit à la loi alors je
me tourne vers guillaume gontard
sénateur de l'isère pour voilà ces deux
mêmes même question cette question de la
responsabilité des fabricants d'armes on
entendait les elle est nouvelle
est-ce que
jean dominique merchet souligné à
l'instant la responsabilité des
politiques est ce qu'on ne se trompe pas
de cible en allant demander des comptes
aux fabricants alors c'était aux
politiques qu'il faut aller demander
d'abord sur ce que montre ce film qui
est plutôt le plutôt intéressant sur moi
je voudrais quand même commencer par ça
c'est de montrer que la guerre contre
les frappes chirurgicales comme on nous
les a présentés n'existe pas et que
derrière il ya des victimes et parfois
hélas souvent il ya des victimes et des
dégâts collatéraux et on a des victimes
civiles on a des enfants comme c'est le
cas sur sur ce crime et donc du coût des
actes particulièrement dramatique je
pense que c'est bien de revenir
là-dessus il n'y a pas de guerre propre
la guerre propre n'existe n'existe pas
et donc derrière oui il ya des armes
il ya des arbres qui sont fabriqués par
des industriels qui sont vendus
c'était c'est effectivement bien de
rappeler que de base il est interdit de
vendre des armes et que du coup c'est
sous des dix ans et que c'est
l'autorisation du gouvernement pour
pouvoir vendre ses armes
bien sûr qu'il ya une responsabilité de
l'état un qui donne ses licences et qui
accepte cette scène donc pour moi ça ça
n'enlève pas totalement la
responsabilité de l'industriel et de la
manière aussi parce qu'il ya toute cette
réflexion dont la procédure est en cours
mais de comment certaines pièces peuvent
arriver et peuvent être vendus aussi
donc il ya aussi tout ce tout ce travail
là mais c'est sur que derrière ça et à
la question de gérer d'une meilleure
transparence d'une meilleure visibilité
sur comment ces licences sont accordés
comment on voit certains pays et pas à
d'autres
et ça a été également rappelé le fait
que ça soit uniquement l'exécutif qui
est la main là dessus et et qui sont au
contrôle en même temps c'est vrai que ce
n'est pas acceptable on sait qu'on a
d'autres pays qui fonctionne
différemment et que pour l'instant le
parlement les parlementaires sont
totalement exclus de cette décision
alors il ya eu quelques petites avancées
avec avec des rapports qu'on nous quand
nous transmet mais on voit bien dans ses
rapports on n'a pas tout la lisibilité
nécessaire pour pouvoir suivre
effectivement commencé ses ventes se
font et comment elle arrive à leurs
destinataires
alors vous avez prononcé de mots
importants la transparence le contrôle
on va évidemment revenir
sur ces sujets là on va aussi entendre
et grandjean du ministère des armées
peut être un mode complément sur cette
question de la responsabilité du
politique
avant cela et mary kay est loin
rapidement oui juste vous complétez
l'autorisation qui est donné par le
gouvernement effectivement il est une
dérogation au principe de prohibition
c'est une autorisation administrative le
ski ce parce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que la licence qui délivrait par
l'état n'exonère pas l'entreprise et du
respect du droit international des
droits de l'homme ou du droit est un
jeune militaire c'est un fait c'est
reconnu au plan international d'un point
de vue juridique les entreprises ont une
responsabilité qui est la leur
l'autorisation donnée par le
gouvernement ne les itunes ne les
exonère pas de leurs responsabilités
lorsqu'elles vendent des armes de
l'utilisation qui en est faite alors
hervé grange ans on est vraiment curieux
d'entendre
voilà ce que le regard du ministère des
armées sur cette affaire précise dans
laquelle une entreprise française est
mise en cause par la justice française
pour des faits qui se sont déroulés sur
un théâtre étrangers ce dont il faut
avoir conscience et que les licences
elles sont accordées au millimètre à
l'issue d'une instruction qui est
extrêmement minutieuses et qui sollicite
beaucoup de services de l'état et donc
c'est des questions sur lesquelles il
faut être très précis la sphère dont il
est question dans le documentaire que
vous avez présenté juste avant c'est la
question d'exportation de composants
électroniques d'usagé assez courant
qu'ils peuvent avoir en réalité
plusieurs usages je ne le sais pas mais
je devine assez aisément que les
composants électroniques dont il est
question dans ce documentaire peuvent
très bien servir à la iron dôme qui est
le système de défense aérienne d'israël
contre les attaques de roquettes
et donc quand on accorde une licence on
essaye d'estimer les usages qui seront
faits de cet armement ou de son
composant mais ce n'est pas toujours
possible d'en spécifier très précisément
les usages et ensuite il ya un principe
c'est le principe de la souveraineté des
états qu'ils acquièrent des harmonies
juste sur la sphère judiciaire sur
laquelle évidemment on ne peut pas se
prononcer cette affaire elle avait été
classée sans suite en 2018 par le
parquet de paris donc il ya un appel a
été déposé donc il ya en cours
d'instruction
mais si le stade que cette affaire a été
classée sans suite en première et va
peut-être un mot aymeric hainaux il me
semble qu'il ya une instruction qui est
en cours tgi de paris et en est en
charge
c'est ce que montrent d'ailleurs le
documentaire après j'imagine qu'on va
rediscuter sur le fait du caractère
millimitré d
des décisions d'exportation mais je suis
étonné quand même d'apprendre que on
sait pas nécessairement lusage
qui est fait d armes qu'eux ou deux
composantes le coup longtemps alors on
n'a pas encore une fois oui super l'anc
est ici ce qui est important pour nous
c'est discuter des principes voilà de la
légitimité à porter plainte dans ce cas
précis alors c'est une décision de 2006
soit là si la justice décide que cette
plainte est recevable
l enquête mais il ya quand même une
question de principe parce que vous
comprenez briquet loin qu'on puisse être
qu'on puisse trouver les raisons
avancées par les avocats peut-être un
peu spécieuse je pense pas du tout il y
à une saine possible de crimes de guerre
on a une famille dont l'habitation
certes situé sur un théâtre de conflits
a été frappé un par les israéliens au
moyen d'un missile alors qu'il n'y avait
pas de cible militaire présente sur zone
donc on est dans le cas d'une frappe
contraire au droit international
humanitaire décider s'ils ont été pris
délibérément pour cible donc il est
normal de chercher des responsabilités
d'ailleurs à l'époque la commission dans
le cadre des nations unies qui avait
enquêté sur les suites de la ferme
beaulieu protectrice avait enquêté sur
ce cas de la famille choe bas je
rappelle que ce n'est pas un cas d
incarner il y a trois enfants qui ont
perdu la mort la ville et deux enfants
qui ont été blessés avec des suites d'un
traumatisme importante
je crois qu'il est important de rappeler
les responsabilités à la fois des
industriels et de l'état jean dominique
merchet on insiste beaucoup depuis tout
à l'heure sur le caractère inédit de
cette enquête est ce que ailleurs dans
le monde à votre connaissance ce type d'
enquête est possible et ce qui en a déjà
eu et qu'elle va dans d'autres pays
européens en allemagne en suède et dans
les pays nordiques bien sûr il ya aidés
à 2 aux états unis même je crois guère
il est à des enquêtes de ce genre c'est
qu'on voit bien que c'est un objet
politique extrêmement sensible cette
question des exportations d'armement des
ventes d'armes
mon opinion si je puis m'exprimer c'est
que c'est une forme les ventes d'armes
pour un pays comme la france en tout cas
sont un mal nécessaire est normal
nécessaire il ya mal aussi
ian cheshire sans doute mais gamal des
choses comme ça voilà sur cette
expression voilà les ventes d'armes à un
mal nécessaire
peut-être une réaction c'est ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure je pense que quand on
vend des armes on sait que c'est fait
pour tuer donc sache pourquoi il faut
quand même l'avoir en tête s'est fait
dans le cadre de guerre et donc c'est
jamais forcément pour un bien le dire
une guerre n'est jamais très positive
par contre oui on sait que ça ça peut
être nécessaire et hélas par contre
c'est justement comment on doit être
très vigilant et comment on doit être
dirai plus que vision sur la manière et
comment un pays démocratique comme la
comme la france doit faire en sorte que
l'on vende césar mais comprennent tout
toutes les précautions
je reprend d'ailleurs je crois que c'est
évident dans le film ce que disait
florence parly on va en parle des armes
comme des baguettes de pain pas tout à
fait
c'est à dire qu' on n'est pas sûr du
commerce classique et donc il doit y
avoir sept cette réglementation est ce
qu'on constate est ce qu ont constaté
plusieurs missions d'information
parlementaires que soit soit en 2000 ou
en 2020 mais la dernière avec les
députés mairie et à barreaux si je relis
ce qu'il disait dans notre pays
l'exécutif est juge et partie de la
qualité du processus d'examen des
demandes de licences notamment quant à
l'examen rigoureux du respect du droit
humanitaire international
cette situation n'est pas à la hauteur
d'une démocratie mature organisant un
contrôle de l'action publique
donc on voit bien que ce n'est pas
nouveau et que les différentes missions
d'information ont bien pointé justement
je dirais manière un petit peu quelque
peu légères dont notre notre démocratie
s'exprime pour accorder cesser ces
licences en matière de ventes d'armes
alors on va en parler vraiment des
ventes d'armes en france de ce qu'elle
représente pour un pays comme le nôtre y
compris leur non seulement sur le plan
économique mais aussi de son influence à
travers le monde et sur les grands
conflits dans le monde vous si vous
signaliez alain tanguy yom gontard cette
phrase qu'on entend effectivement dans
le film on ne vend pas des armes comme
on vend des débats getz et florence
parly la ministre des armées
chi chi chi chi le dit sur le plan du
droit on l'a bien compris c'est évident
ça vous l'avez bien expliquée sur le
plan de vue du commerce et de la manière
de
de vendre peut-être un peu moins évident
il ya cet extrait assez surprenant dans
le film very qu'on le regarde et puis je
voudrais ensuite un commentaire
à paris tous les deux ans le salon
eurosatory est la vitrine de cette
industrie florissante
un rendez vous incontournable pour les
vendeurs et les acheteurs venus du monde
entier en juin 2018 parmi les exposants
la société extelia vente son savoir
faire et ses produits stars
alors chez ikks eliane nous avons une
division qui est une gpu qui s'appelle
électromécanique dans lequel on fait des
produits qui sont des bijoux
technologiques de la haute couture et
qui nécessite un savoir-faire une
connaissance très précise c'est un
commerce le commerce des armes ça
représente beaucoup d'argent dans notre
économie il faut peut-être s'arrêter un
tout petit peu sur ceux sur 7 sur ce
point sur ce que représente ce secteur
notamment en terme donc de puissance et
d'emploi jean dominique merchet ça
s'apaise dans notre économie autour
d'eux en termes l'ex les exports les
exportations autour de quoi sa skoda
figureront plusieurs milliards en
général on exporte pour environ 8
milliards d'euros par an un peu moins
l'an dernier un peu moins l'an dernier
mais c'est une année tellement
particulier ce thème en particulière à
cause de l'épidémie de covile temps en
général 8 milliards faut bien voir que
dans un pays désindustrialisés comme la
france dont la balance commerciale est
déficitaire structurellement dont
l'industrie se porte mal le secteur de
l'armement est un des rares secteurs
français qui se portent bien
donc c'est quand même un élément à
prendre en compte entre dans le complexe
sa présence à présent des emplois ça
présente de désinvestissement importance
à présent mais je pense que la dimension
économique au sens de ce que ça rapporte
en termes d'emploi ou pour la balle le
commerce extérieur n'est pas la question
essentielle
la question essentielle encore une fois
c'est une question politique
si l'on veut maintenir un minimum
d'autonomie stratégiques techniques ses
terres la capacité des français et des
européens a assuré par eux même leur
défense et non pas en remettre
totalement par exemple aux états unis vu
la taille de notre pays nous n'avons pas
d'autre choix que d'exporter nous
n'avons pas un marché intérieur
suffisants pour absorber comme les
américains pour un peuvent la voir
il exporte ses leurs surplus qu'ils
exportent nous sur une ex porte pas
notre modèle économique ne fonctionne
pas quand ce qu'ils veulent ce que ça
signifie quelque chose de simple si
notre modèle économique ne fonctionne
pas ou et à des coûts démesurés
ça veut dire qu'on perd notre autonomie
technique et en perdant des notes on
donne notre autonomie technologique
on perd notre autonomie politique donc
c'est ça c'est ça l'enjeu c'est pas
c'est pas cinquante mille emplois ici ou
là c'est vrai on notait de ma cité de la
france à continuer et de l'europe a
continué à peser de manière autonome
dans les affaires mondiales et sur sa
propre sécurité
avec grandjean là dessus vous êtes
d'accord avec ce que vient de dire jean
dominique merchet sur le fait que avant
d'être une question économique c'est la
vente d'armes pour la france est une
question politique
ça peut paraître paradoxal mais les
exportations d'armements c'est une
condition de notre souveraineté
jean dominique merchet là c'est bien
décrit on a deux cent mille emplois dans
notre industrie de défense en france des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois qualifiés
et effectivement cette industrie de
défense
elle marche sur deux jambes il ya la
jambe qui est les commandes nationales
c'est à peu près 10 milliards d'euros
chaque année qu'on injecte dans
l'économie de défense pour reconstruire
des sous marins des avions de chasse des
chars etc
et il ya à peu près dix mille dards ça
dépend des années d'exportation et nos
bureaux d'études nos chaînes de
production sont dimensionnés et ne
peuvent tenir debout que si elle marche
sur les deux jambes et si la jambe
export devait s'arrêter
eh bien il n'y aurait plus de gens de
national non plus on a en france un
modèle d'armée complet on veut
intervenir dans tous les segments du
combat moderne et donc on a besoin
quelque part c'est assez triviale mais
d'amortir les coûts de développement
d'amortir les frais fixes des usines
d'armement en vendant à l'exportation se
sont sur ce sujet emeric et le 20h et
amnesty international
en france le cet argument de la
souveraineté du fait que pour avoir pour
pouvoir assurer sa propre sécurité on
peut avoir besoin de vendre des armes
pour assurer son autonomie stratégique
vous l'entendez cet argument alors oui
c'est un argument que nous entendons
nous essayons évidemment
de le comprendre mais il faut comprendre
qui est amnistie internationale amnesty
international france est une ong qui ne
travaille pas sur ce type d'engin de
souveraineté au sens recherches
indépendantes emploient l'adn d'amnesty
international c'est la défense et la
promotion des droits de l'homme il
droite nationale mérite donc moi ce que
je vois essentiellement et les cerveaux
depuis les années soixante dix quand on
parle de bain dufry l'armement
d'exportation on met en avant
effectivement les questions économiques
les questions d'indépendance et settat
mais c'est tellement mis en avant qu'on
ne peut plus finalement ensuite avoir un
débat construit sur comment on exporte
est acquis parce que le coeur du sujet
finalement c'est acquis en export et
pour quoi faire
amnesty international nous n'avons pas
de position de principe comme r d art je
le rappelle nous dénonçons les
transferts d'armes que nous considérons
comme irresponsable voire illégales
illégaux au regard du droit
international et c'est pas pour rien que
nous avons saisi le bureau de la
procureure de la coop et à
l'international en décembre 2019 à
l'initiative d'une autre ong basée en
allemagne pour travailler sur
l'éventuelle responsabilité
d'industriels européens
enfin deux représentants des frais
l'européen et de représentants dans les
gouvernements européens notamment en
france qui ont contribué à favoriser
l'exportation vers l'arabie saoudite ou
les emirats engagé dans confiant il ya
maintenant que nous ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de mettre en parallèle
est de faire se rejoindre les deux
sujets l'intérêt économique et le
respect du droit international
ces deux questions à un moment ou un
autre se rencontrent c'est pas soit là
on n'est pas nécessairement un moment
dans une contradiction il faut un moment
choisir le droit international est très
clair sous traitées sur commères des
heures la position commune de l'union
européenne vous exportez pas d'armes
pour faire ça s'il existe un risque que
césar pu servir à commettre des
violations graves du droit international
des droits de l'homme ou humanitaires
une réaction est très grand il ya
effectivement l'aspect de souveraineté
économique dont on a parlé juste avant
mais la première raison pour laquelle on
vend des arguments c'est accompagné des
états qui sont des partenaires vous avez
cités parce que ce sont souvent les pays
qu'on met en exergue dans ces débats les
pays du golfe arabo persique mais
l'arabie saoudite les émirats arabes
unis sont même si certains ne veulent
pas l'entendre des partenaires qui lutte
contre al qaïda dans la péninsule arabe
qui sont ceux qui étaient à l'origine
des attentats de charlie hebdo ce sont
précisément l'arabie saoudite et les
émirats arabes unis combien de
ressortissants avons-nous dans le golfe
arabo-persique nous en avons trente
mille ces gens là ils sont aussi
sécurisé par le fait qu'il y ait une
coopération d'armement avec ce pays et
enfin nul besoin de vous rappeler que à
peu près 30% de notre approvisionnement
en énergie transitent par le détroit
d'ormuz et que nous avons un intérêt
objectif à ce que l'iran n'est pas le
contrôle du détroit d'ormuz et que les
autres pays du golfe arabo-persique
puisse maintenir leur souveraineté dans
leurs eaux territoriales
et aussi des régions géopolitique très
profonde a qui justifie ce commerce des
armements
jean dominique merchet oui c'est une
question importante que carey grange
vient de soulever mais je pense qu'on
peut la critiquer cette position parce
que on comprend pas bien on comprend
plus très bien ce qui est la priorité
aujourd'hui en france est-ce que la
priorité c'est elle et géopolitique
c'est à dire d'avoir des choix
géopolitiques par exemple docilité à
l'iran et donc de soutenir des états
hostiles à l'iran et en aide ou à la
chine par exemple en soutenant
l'australie où est ce que c'est parce
que nous vendons des armes à ces pays et
que ces pays nous demande d'un soutien
politique qui est une condition pour
qu'ils achètent nos armes
le client est roi aussi en matière
d'armement on comprend pas bien quel est
le degré d'autonomie de décision de la
france à ce niveau là est ce que d'abord
la priorité les géopolitique et nous
entraîne à faire du commerce ou est ce
qu'elle est d'abord commercial ce qui à
mon avis est légitime elle est d'abord
commercial s e commerce nous entraîne à
des alliances politiques qui nous
emmènent parfois dans des conflits dans
lesquels on a rien à faire c'est un vrai
sujet qui doit être débattu notamment
dans ceux par l'europarlement je pensais
mais aussi dans les médias dans
l'opinion avec les ong avec tout bon
parce que c'est la politique de la
france qui est en jeu dans une affaire
comme ça un complément rapide d'hervé
grandjean puis ensuite on tournera vers
notre sénateur parce qu'effectivement la
question du contrôle de la transparence
dont on parle ces deux questions très
importantes et on va un peu
approfondirait grand lemps d'abord juste
pour donner un exemple les émirats
arabes unis nous
vont aux émirats arabes unis une base
navale où de nombreux bâtiments de la
marine nationale font escale nous avons
une base aérienne depuis laquelle
d'école à peu près chaque jour trois ou
quatre rafale qui vont frapper des ch en
syrie et en irak
donc on voit bien que nous avons besoin
également de ses points d'appui que
peuvent constituer les pays avec
lesquels nous commerçants et donc de la
priorité c'est d'abord une alliance
géopolitique et géostratégie alors on a
bien compris les enjeux stratégiques et
des seins je trouverais ndt et des
enjeux commerciaux des enjeux
industriels tout ça s'entremêlent c'est
très complexe mais tout ça se fait dans
un état de droit qui respecte des règles
ya des mots importants qu'on était quoi
qui ont été prononcées depuis 7 7 le
début de cette émission la question des
contrôles notamment sur ce sujet est
vrai qu'on approfondisse avec vous
guillaumont tard on sentait bien tout à
l'heure dans votre première intervention
que c'est peut-être là que le bât blesse
en france il ya un problème selon vous
de contrôler notamment de contrôle du
parlement sur la question des ventes
d'armes
oui c'est bien là toute là toute la
problématique bien sûr qu'il ya une
industrie
il ya une industrie de la bct rappeler
deux sortes de sorte que ça concerne
plus de cent mille emplois directs et
indirects je veux dire on reviendra pas
là d'un autre côté le fait qu'ils aient
une industrie d'armes florissante c'est
pas une bonne santé ça ça marque pas une
bonne santé de la planète
mais même si on se met dans cet aspect
là et dans l'aspect commercial ce que je
vois et différents rapports c'est
notamment la réticence des banques à
investir dans l'industrie de la défense
pourquoi justement parce que il ya sept
ce risque il est justement un contrôle
insuffisant et un manque de transparence
donc on a tout intérêt même les
industriels ont intérêt à ce qu'ils
aient une meilleure clarté meilleure
visibilité entre les décisions des
exécutifs rendre ce que peut faire le
parlement et qu'on comprenne très bien
parlementaire vous êtes informés chaque
année sur cette question des ventes
d'armes il ya il ya un contrôle réel du
parlement oui ou non va donc se faire
rire on a un rapport avec des
informations mais ces informations
justement qui ne nous permettent pas
d'avoir un suivi par exemple sur
qu'est-ce que fin ou
ce couvent à l'armement et comment il
est vendu à trois chansons qu'elle il
faut revenir c'est pas de vente à des
états autoritaires et répressifs ya un
respect ça a été rappelé des engagements
internationaux ça c'est des choses qui
peuvent être très clair et puis sow et
puis un sujet européen
moi qui me paraît indispensable sur la
création d'industries en européenne et
d'avoir aidé de travailler sur un modèle
commun de contrôle au niveau européen au
niveau des européens on a 27 manière de
contrôler alors quand en 2008
je crois il y avait une position commune
européenne avec huit critères qui
avaient été établies la france ne ne
respecte pas l'ensemble de ces critères
donc qu'a nécessité de revenir à ça
d'avoir un contrôle commun elles surtout
si on veut aller vers une réflexion et
une armée européenne
il me semble que c'est très important qu
au moins se dirige on se dirige vers ça
et que bien sûr il ya aussi une
ouverture vers le parlement mais que du
coup on arrive à voir une homogénéité
dans la manière et dans le second
contrôle à l'échelle européenne
hervé grange en une réaction pas de
vente aux états autoritaires et au
minimum le respect des traités que la
france a signé
si on écoute guillaume gontard sur ces
deux points en tout cas là la france à
on aurait des choses à redire
il est évident que les traités
internationaux sont respectés que ce
soit le droit international humanitaire
le traité sur le commerce des armes
ces choses là sont évidemment ausculté
d'extrêmement près et c'est bien à
l'aune de ces grands textes là dont nous
sommes partie que nous attribuons ou pas
des licences il faudrait pas laisser
penser que une demande industrielle se
traduit nécessairement par un accord de
l'exécutif en matière de licence il y à
tous les ans des matériels qui sont
refusés alors peut-être je peux essayer
de donner quelques illustrations de
matériel que nous avons refusé l'année
dernière par exemple nous avons refusé
du matériel de maintien de l'ordre pour
la police de hong kong
nous avons refusé du matériel pour des
forces spéciales d'un pays africain
nous avons refusé un système
d'interception de communications pour un
pays d'asie du sud tous les ans en plus
du rapport qui est transmis au parlement
généralement le 1er juin de chaque année
la ministre et florence parly se rend
devant le parlement et répond pendant de
nombreuses heures aux questions qui sont
posées par les parlementaires effet
toute la transparence qui est faisable
dans le respect du secret de la défense
nationale et du secret des affaires
aymeric et l'humain
la france respecte t-elle vraiment selon
vous les traitez qu'elle a signés en
matière de ventes d'armes
écoutez je crois qu'il faut être clair
il a été dit qu'effectivement il fallait
un contrôle parlementaire oui il faut un
contrôle parlementaire
pourquoi parce qu'il n'ya pas contre
parlementaire aujourd'hui
institutionnalisée permanent comme le
proposent les députés jacques maire
michèle tabarot dans le rapport de
novembre 2020 ça n'existe pas la
transparence à l'insuffisante florence
parly n'ai pas eu 10 youn et parlant des
heures allées auditionné pendant un
certain nombre d'heures sur le sujet et
je pense et c'est indubitable
aujourd'hui on doit avoir ce contrôle
parlementaire parce que lorsque
j'entends ce que me dit monsieur hervé
grandjean sur les ventes d'armes à
l'arabie saoudite et aux émirats arabes
unis où on prend en compte
essentiellement les intérêts
géopolitiques le positionnement de nos
forces et qu'on ne prend pas en compte
la pratique de la guerre des sables de
la coalition militaire engagée au yémen
cela cela pose un vrai souci en termes
de volonté de montrer que l'on respecte
le droit international trade show
commerce des armes le yémen c'est à des
milliers de frappes aériennes
il y en a eu plus de 3000 en décembre
2020 ce sont des hôpitaux des écoles à
keith ont visé des mosquées
deschamps attendait c'est important de
de retenir c'est que sur le conflit au
yémen il y est délibérée qui a été mise
en place de frappes indiscriminées
disproportionnée consistant à viser des
civils
donc si on veut un vrai débat
aujourd'hui sur la transparence et le
contrôle
il faut clairement s'en donner les
moyens pourquoi parce que sinon nous
serons toujours confrontée à une vision
en france où on a d'un côté une parole
qui est celle des ong
celle du ministère des armées et aucun
endroit où on se retrouve on puisse
discuter et débattre quand j'entends les
refus qui sont avec ton suave et
grandjean a parlé
à titre d'exemple pourquoi ces refus ne
figurent pas dans le rapport au
parlement
pourquoi ils ne sont pas listés dans le
rapport au parlement on a 19 rochus qui
sont exprimées pour cette année dernière
pardon mais sans explication d'un mot un
bout de réponse rapide d'hervé grandjean
sur ce sujet précis pourquoi voilà
certaines choses ne figurent pas dans le
rapport qui a été fourni aux
parlementaires vous voyez je viens de
vous donner ces informations là de
manière publique donc il n'y a pas la
rétention d'information outrancière bon
vous semble et que vous semblez attribué
au ministère d désarmés ce qu'il faut
ajouter en plus de ses 19 refus de
licence et qu'il ya l'immensité des
refus qui est en fait de l'auto censure
c'est à dire qu'avant de demander une
autorisation d'exportation les
industriels parle avec l'état et nous
les décourage ont toujours beaucoup de
10 dès qu'ils pourraient avoir à
attendre du matériel monde et christelle
morel pays donc le chiffre paraît
tellement en fait il est beaucoup
beaucoup plus massif
parce qu'il ya une discussion en amont
sur scène il faut à l'évidence améliorer
le contrôle et notamment le contrôle le
contrôle pas simplement l'information
des assemblées du peut faire des
assemblées parlementaires en français ça
me semble absolument évident et
d'ailleurs c'est possible parce que
pendant deux années autour d'un autre
sujet considéré comme tabou on pourrait
en parler le renseignement pendant des
années les romans il faut pas du tout
que leur enseignement que les
parlementaires s'occupe du renseignement
et puis on peut le faire on peut si on
l'a fait pour le renseignement qui est
un dossier ô combien sensible
on peut le faire pour les exportations
d'armement cela dit hervé grosjean a
prononcé un mot qui est à moi pour
tendance est dans cette affaire celui du
secret des affaires
je rappelle qu il s'agit de contrats
commerciaux et le client encore une fois
est roi en faisant voler les deux oui
mais il y a le secret de la défense
nationale
et puis a le secret de la faire vous
avez des clients qui ont pas envie de
dire qu'ils achètent telle ou telle
chose
c'est du commerce non on est obligé d'en
tenir compte
c'est compliqué mais il faut comme l'a
très bien dit et comment il l'a très
bien dit il faut qu'il ya un endroit où
on puisse discuter de ça et ça ça
n'existe pas donc le parlement sa 2
servir à ça et il y a des secrets
évident il faut savoir gérer ça mais il
faut qu'on en discute sur ce sujet
guillaume gontard depuis tout à l'heure
on dit information control question
peut-être un peu naïve mais vraiment
qu'est ce qu'il faudrait pour qu'il y
ait un contrôle effectif pour au niveau
du sénat notamment tout simplement il
suffit de jugement je disais de relire
les rapports parlementaires et ce qui
avait été proposé et c'est en fait sur
sur les rapports qui nous sont rendus
actuellement on voit bien que les
statistiques qui sont fournis à reste
largement insuffisante et hervé grange
ans quand il explique équilibre voilà je
vous dit tout il montre bien qu'on a
cette nécessité de savoir et que en plus
il n'y a rien avec ce qui a rien à
cacher autant qu'il y ait que cet espace
justement parlementaire servent à ça par
exemple quels sont les types de
matériels de guerre l'isolella type et
la quantité on n'a pas dans ses rapports
à quel destinataire utilisateur final on
ne sait pas non plus pour quelle
utilisation finale ce n'est pas non plus
indiqué si on n'a pas ces éléments là
comment du coup on peut juger que
justement la france applique bien les
règles à l'exportation qu'elle est bien
dans les règles acceptées dans les dents
les engagements internationaux si on n'a
pas ces éléments là comment le parlement
peut juger de ça et là actuellement
c'est juste entre exécutif et exécute
puisque c'est le cas de la tutelle sous
la tutelle du premier ministre et dont
il n'ya pas se contrôler moi je pense
que ça soit le gouvernement que ce soit
les industriels tout le monde aurait
intérêt justement à ouvrir ce contrôle à
permettre ce contrôle parlementaire
justement pour clarifier les choses et
puis je reviens aussi sur sur l'échelle
européenne parce que moi ça me paraît
important que la france soit le modèle
est pour l'instant on est loin de là
parmi les parmi les 27
pour montrer justement et pour montrer
justement ce ce ce modèle de deux
fonctionnement en matière de
transparence sur la vente sur la vente
d'armes et qui est d'ailleurs un
préalable si on veut réellement
construira fonctionnement à l'échelle
européenne
alors qu'on termine là dessus jean
dominique merchet
les industriels ça a été dit à l'instant
votre avis là-dessus ont un intérêt
aurait presque intérêts en tous cas
n'aurait rien à perdre ce qui est un
contrôle plus strict de la part des
sénateurs et des députés
c'est ça dépend des dossiers et vous
avez des dossiers où ils seront unis
n'ont manifestement pas intérêt mais
globalement ça légitime des ventes
d'armes parce que cet argument mois
cynique ou réaliste voilà en respectant
le droit scrupuleusement les règles
l'état de droit s'annonce affaibli par
rapport à des pays qui n'ont pas de
scrupules
oui mais on n'est pas obligé de se
comparer au pire on peut aussi se
comparer aux meilleurs et donc
effectivement ça pourrait aider du sart
est d'ailleurs on vas y on y sera un peu
obligé dans la mesure où beaucoup de
programmes d'armement les les grands
programmes d'armement du futur ce faux
en coopération internationale et donc on
sera obligé de trouver des terrains
d'entente avec nos grands partenaires
notamment les allemands sur la manière
dont on exportera nos futurs matériel or
les allemands sont plus une vraie
démocratie parlementaire dans lequel
leur parlement joue un rôle beaucoup
plus important que chez nous et il
faudra donc qu'on trouve des compromis
oui les industriels coque mais on a dit
ça je reviens à comparer avec les
services avec le contrôle du
renseignement pendant des années on a
dit ah oui mais les services d'urgence
ne veulent absolument pas qu'on
s'appelle ne révèle pas du tout ils ont
au contraire trouvé dans ce le contrôle
parlementaire une forme de légitimité
qui leur manquait et on peut imaginer ça
dans le domaine des exportations
d'armements certains en souffriront la
majorité bénéficieront en terme d'image
de respect et le démocratie mais je vous
donne la parole à des grands noms pour
conclure très rapidement au niveau
européen quand un pays refuse il le fait
savoir aux autres pays européens qui
généralement applique la même
jurisprudence donc il ya de plus en plus
une uniformité des décisions qui sont
prises à l'échelle européenne
ensuite pour rebondir sur la question du
renseignement et il est évidemment
légitime que le parlement contrôler
l'action du gouvernement néanmoins aux
termes de la constitution la politique
de défense et la politique des affaires
étrangères ressort principalement du
pouvoir exécutif
merci beaucoup ce débat et d'avant n'est
pas épuisé mais notre temps pour le coup
notre temps à partie il l'est merci à
tous les quatre d'avoir d'avoir éclairé
et ce débat je vais renvoyer quand même
au rapport annuel sur les exportations
d'armement de la france qui était remis
la semaine dernière au parlement on en a
beaucoup parlé dans l'émission il est
consultable sur le site du ministère des
armées le lien nous vous remettrons sur
la page d'accueil de l'émission merci à
chacun et à chacune de nous avoir suivi
et à très bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]